hey guys justin and peter here with a
game spot news breakdown so amazon just
announced the kindle fire TV and this is
obviously not a competitor for the xbox
one or the ps4 but it is definitely
going to be going up against the roku
box and people are going to compare this
favorably or unfavorably to the to the
ouya is this is this a better from from
what we know i mean we've seen a couple
games we've seen the specs is this
something that we should be excited
about or just maybe not something that
we should care about it all uh well it's
very interesting i think it depends on
what your gaming ecosystem is like at
home what Amazon is doing is creating a
platform to take advantage of the amazon
marketplace which is currently available
on you know other kindle devices and
android devices as well and this is an
android based system but you're not
going to be able to use google play so
you're immediately sort of you know
you're cut off from a lot of the things
that make android great and forced to
use amazon services i think that is the
the linchpin that's sort of gonna cause
the biggest you know issue for this
going forward at least in the eyes of
gamers who are used to getting all sorts
of great things out of the box right
this is strictly amazon stuff but having
that amazon name seems really important
like I i love amazon i order also to
crap from amazon is that not something
that is more of a positive well i mean
it's a good thing i think Amazon shows
that they're taking gaming a little bit
more seriously than to have in the past
they've got the controller there's a
dedicated graphics processor on board
for the the fire TV but you know i don't
think that we're going to see a lot of
games that are going to entice people
away from their consoles the gaming
announced today was called have sev SUV
there's a third person shooter with
tower defense element and it's sci-fi ii
and you know it's reminiscent of i get
maybe halo is the closest thing I could
compare to take a third person halo with
tower defense titanfall they have robots
yeah I don't know it's it's all so
unexcited I think this is really for
someone who isn't a console gamer who is
not a pc gamer to sort of say look you
know we've got your streaming services
you can do amazon prime good
yo Netflix Hulu and you can play games
we've got a controller that is you know
could be great less yet that's what they
said they're they're aiming the set this
is add guys who have an iPad who who do
mobile gaming primarily and don't really
game on console so in that sense it's
not even aimed at us and we already have
like five five devices in my home that
stream netflix and hulu and amazon video
and i don't feel like i need something
like this it is there a reason that I
would want to pick one up I know the
only reason I'm interested in it is
because of the hardware and the fact
that it's designed to work with the
Android operating system Amazon's OS is
based off of the jelly bean version of
Android which is slightly outdated now
they're up to a kit kat but what's
important there is the dev community for
android devices are really strong and
really clever so if someone can figure
out a way to run the standard vanilla
Android operating system on this and
open it up I think then that's an
interesting proposition for people like
ourselves who maybe want to emulate old
games right or do other things are the
Android that we're used to apart from
that I know I'm not very interested
because what I could get from amazon i
can already get with other devices that
i already currently own like the Ouya
like the Ouya but not even necessarily
the Ouya you know i mean it's it's it's
just that I there's nothing enticing for
me know what about you Oh saying that it
has two gigs of ram and a quad-core
processor like that sounds really
interesting like that makes it sound
more appealing than it is but at the
same time I'm I always feel kind of
burned by android games like I want a
full console experience and right
android or is always a little bit
disappointing I mean those are basically
mobile games and I don't want to play
those on my TV I I'm gonna play my TV
that's for xbox one that's for ps4 but i
also don't feel like I'm the market for
this because I'm gonna watch netflix on
one of the many many other things that
we have the price point is that a good
price point ninety nine dollars for the
base box if you want a controller which
just looks like an xbox controller
that's another forty dollars right not a
cheaper bundle yeah you will be able to
use the remote the standard remote that
comes with it as a controller for some
games I flink like shooters price and
one button right yeah the value is there
right because right now the apple TV
doesn't necessarily have competing
hardware
that offers the same feature set like
you can't play games on it for example
it has local storage but you can't use
it yeah they're gonna go they're going
against Apple TV and Roku those are
their main competitors not Microsoft not
Sony right so for one hundred and forty
dollars to get that system with a
controller to me seems like it's asking
a lot I think you also get ten dollars
worth of credits for the store and the
average game is a dollar eighty five and
they have thousands of free games so
maybe you get a lot of stuff for your
dollar but is that stuff good I don't
know it's still so early I think it's
going to be interesting to see how
seriously amazon takes the gaming
portion of this and i think one of the
most interesting things is that it's
available right now like they've made
the announcement and basically said and
it's in the stores now we went on amazon
and actually ordered one ourselves are
doing amazon prime overnight shipping so
we're gonna have it in the office we're
gonna be trying it out and we'll get to
see just how fun or not fun it is so
stay tuned to gamespot com as for more
info on the Amazon fire TV